when I would come to California for the
first initial time that came to 29 palms
like it clears my head let's thought of
your work is very collage like not a
literal way of the process when it's
working well it is a collage language
image decoration somehow like position
installation you're kind of taking
diverse illness he finds garbage or
capture as images and kind of creates
friction to create a feeling of
something has happened or will happen to
try this from like an especially good
event I like it to look theatrical and
like a set or like what just happened to
hear or white one might happen here but
what I make is the present Darren lies
the sadness that people will uncover in
my work